[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
la france aurait un problème de
séparatisme un problème de laïcité nous
dit on autrefois on aurait dit un
problèmes d'assimilation un mot qui
faisait l'unanimité l'époque mais que
l'on n'utilise plus on lui préfère
l'intégration je reçois aujourd'hui
raphaël d'oran pour son nouveau livre le
rêve de l'assimilation de la grèce
antique à nos jours qui vient de
paraître chez passé composé
et l'on commence tout de suite par notre
époque comme c'est la tradition dans
cette émission qu'est ce qui caractérise
ce début de xxième siècle voici les
masques l'image que vous avez choisi
raphaël nous l'expliqué douteux
représente-t-elle c'était une
illustration qui date de la fin du 19e
siècle et qui a été fait par un
personnage qui s'appelle albert robida
une sorte d'illustrateurs écrivain et
passionné de futurisme qui essayez
d'imaginer la vie au xxème siècle il a
fait plusieurs livre d'anticipation en
fait quasiment de science fiction sur la
vie au xxème siècle vu depuis la
décennie 1890 et c'est assez drôle
puisque là en l'occurrence il est un
dessin qui représente une invention
qu'il attribue au 20e siècle et qui
s'appelle le téléphone aux scop c'est à
dire en fait exactement la
visioconférence qu'on est en train de
faire vous et moi en ce moment ça a
l'air de mieux marché d'ailleurs au
xixème siècle en 1890 qu'aujourd'hui
ouzou mais les autres skype ne sont pas
toujours aussi efficace là qu'on voit un
grand père je crois qu'ils parlent avec
sa fille son épouse qui sont dans des
pays étrangers
voilà c'est ça il faut dire que j'ai sa
fille est dans un pays étranger sont son
épouse aussi et qu' ils prennent l'apéro
comme on le faisait pendant le
confinement comme ça alors il vraiment
et et robidas alors c'est un nom qui
restait 1 robidas il est très important
mais il est il y avait un côté extra
lucide l'ain
sauf qu'ils se trompaient d'un siècle en
fait eh bien je trouve que c'est le
genre de dessin et de
de prophétie qui rend assez optimiste en
fait sur le progrès technologique parce
que finalement il ya des gens qui
regardent dans le l'état technologique
de leur époque se disent peut-être que
demain on aura ça et effectivement
demain on a eu ça un petit peu plus tard
quand même que ce qu'ils prévoyaient
puisque lui je crois qu'ils se situent
en 1950 dans sa prévision en fait c'est
arrivé cinquante ans plus tard mais ça
se trouve que ce qu'on nous dit de baux
sur la technologie de demain verra
effectivement le jour
on va bien voir et bien commençons
[Musique]
raphaël d'orange nous avait reçus pour
votre livre précédent encore quand rome
inventait le le populisme
aujourd'hui vous publiez le rêve de
l'assimilation et pour écrire seul et
vous êtes remonté
là encore à la grèce antique l empire
romain
d'où vous vient cette passion d'aller
chercher les germes de nos polémiques
actuelles dans l'antiquité
alors voici une sorte de déformation
parce que professionnel puisque c'est
une formation d'études classiques de
littérature antique de grec et de latin
alors à chaque fois que je me pose une
question sur un problème actuel me
demande un peu ce que les grecs et les
romains en pensée et en plus je trouve
qu'on a
vous savez tous les toute l'histoire de
l'occident finalement c'est une sorte de
réinvention perpétuelle de ce qu'on
s'imagine avoir été l'antiquité sur le
moyen-âge avec des rois il voulait
reconstruire à l'empiré romain à la
renaissance évidemment on veut faire ont
retrouvé la gréco romains à l'époque
classique à l'époque néoclassique y est
même encore jusqu aux années 30
peut-être on a cette impression que pour
aller de l'avant pour progresser il faut
toujours réinventer l'antiquité et voilà
je partage un peu cette ce sentiment là
qu'il faut toujours se pencher sur cette
civilisation là pour comprendre ce qui
nous arrive aujourd'hui alors
l'assimilation je le disais en
introduction de cette émission elle a
fait l'unanimité en france et ça n'est
plus le cas aujourd'hui on parle
d'intégration
alors évidemment c'est quoi la
différence c'est quoi la simulation et
ckoi l'intégration affectivement
maintenant on a plutôt peur d'utiliser
le mot assimilation l'assimilation jeu
l'a défini dans le livre de manière
assez simple en disant que c'est la
pratique qui consiste à exiger de
l'étranger ils deviennent semblables à
nous c'est à dire qu'ils adoptent les
mêmes comportements les mêmes us et
coutumes les mêmes traditions que naît
la population qui l'accueille
voilà c'est une définition très
matérielle finalement pour moi la
simulation ça concerne des objets
concrets c'est à dire la manière de se
vêtir de manger de faire la fête de
concevoir les relations hommes-femmes
c'est vraiment la vie quotidienne qui
est concerné par l'assimilation
alors que je pense que l'intégration se
définit plutôt comme le phénomène l'ours
par lequel un étranger trouve une place
dans la société arrive à trouver un
emploi
des conditions de vie correcte mais sans
forcément se métamorphose et
culturellement sans forcément chercher à
ressembler à devenir identique à la
population qu'il accueille
simplement il vit à côté d'eux mais ils
ne leur ressemblent pas nécessairement
donc c'est vraiment de deux notions
assez différentes
et effectivement aujourd'hui on a plutôt
tendance à parler d'intégration que
d'assimilation pour des raisons
multiples la première je pense en france
c'est que la simulation a été utilisée
notamment dans le contexte colonial et
donc forcément maintenant ça a des
relents coloniaux et on a un peu peur
d'utiliser ce mot là alors même qu'il ne
se réduit pas à recoller alors on a
compris est similaire chez oak et
intégration ok mais alors quand on est
nous les français par exemple totalement
américanisé qu'est ce que est ce qu'il
ya un mot ouais moi je parlerai dans ce
cas là plutôt d'acculturation pour
ajouter un troisième terme à ces
distinctions l'acculturation ce serait
simplement quand deux populations ont
des contacts qu'elle échange entre elles
et qu'elles ce qu'elles adoptent parfois
l'une l'autre d'ailleurs des des
coutumes ou des pratiques qui viennent
de l'autre civilisation de l'autre
culture mais sans qu'il ait dû toute
volonté de transformer les gens du pays
d'à côté en décembre a blessé les
américains ne veulent absolument fin je
ne crois pas que les américains
cherchent absolument à rendre les
français totalement américain alors
donner la citoyenneté américaine à leur
fallait faire parler anglais et à les
habiller voile américaine en numérique
je pense que voilà une vraie différence
entre l'acculturation qui est un
phénomène disons spontanée presque de
frottement et l'assimilation qui est une
vraie volonté politique et une sorte de
destins on s'avise à transformer
fondamentalement la vie des individus
alors pourquoi cherche-t-on à assimiler
quel est le quel est le but
il ya plusieurs buts selon les
civilisations les sociétés qui
pratiquent la simulation
on peut dire qu'il ya deux buts deux
raisons principales pour lesquelles on
peut vouloir assimiler la première
raison elle est assez basique c'est de
dire que une société point de croire
qu'une société est plus forte
elle est plus stable elle est plus
solide lorsque ses membres sont se
ressemblent culturellement mais
lorsqu'il ya une homogénéité culturelle
une harmonie culturel entre entre ses
membres c'est l'idée que déjà machiavel
faisait remarquer dans le prince il le
conseille donc aux princes qui à qui est
dédiée le livre de plus tôt quérir des
provinces dont les moeurs des habitants
sont semblables aux moeurs des habitants
du pays d'origine en jugeant que ce sera
plus simple pour le pouvoir en place de
gouverner ce pays parce que comme ça il
y aura moins de troubles sociaux il y
aura moins de deux conflits à moindre
risque de dislocation de ce pays donc
c'est une idée assez basique d'un point
de vue politique il ya aussi d'ailleurs
des sociologues et des psychologues qui
se sont un peu penché sur la question en
remarquant par exemple que dans une des
bataillons de l'armée américaine les
soldats les groupes les bataillons qui
avait des soldats venus plutôt de la
même région
qui donc partager des codes communs la
même région américaine avait plus
confiance les uns contre les autres que
des bataillons plus plus divers
provenant d'origine diverse
donc je vois là il ya peut-être un effet
de ce genre là qui justifie que on
assimile étrangers pour éviter que il ya
une trop grande hétérogénéité culturel à
l'intérieur d'une communauté
une autre raison possible pour vouloir
assimiler elle est assez différente
c'est de croire que sa propre
civilisation est supérieure à celle des
autres et notamment à celles de
l'étranger qu'on veut c'est l'idée est
donc dans ce cas là on pense que c'est
une sorte de devoir moral de données à
l'étranger
le bénéfice de notre civilisation quand
juge supérieur c'est un peu la mentalité
de la france de la troisième république
il y avait de voir deux voire de
civilisation justifiait selon l'est
républicain de l'époque la colonisation
il fallait apporter la culture française
et notamment les valeurs de la
révolution française
celles qui ont été inventé à la fin
xviiie siècle celle des lumières et dont
jugé qu'il fallait il que ce thème à
devoir une obligation de la france de
les apporter au reste du monde et
d'abord non seulement à ceux aux
étrangers qui venaient en france mais
aussi aux dents
jeunes là où la france avait conquis son
empire colonial alors voyons maintenant
vous avez étudié dans ce livre si
civilisations différentes comment elle
gérait le rapport à l'assimiler à
sionisme comme on dit commençons par les
grecs
vous dites là elle ne que les grecs ne
connaissent pas les grecs période
classique bien sûr ne connaissent pas la
civilisation en tant que tel eux ils et
les knees et l'elysée le leurs voisins
s'ils comprennent mais ils n'ont pas
l'impression de les essayer de les
assimiler pour autant est-ce qu'ils sont
conscients qu'ils assimilent les grecs
alors les grecs effectivement à l'époque
classique celle qu'on connaît le mieux
un celle d'athènes et de sparte de leur
apogée
les grecs ne sont pas très assimilateur
d'abord parce que ils sont divisés
les grecs la civilisation grecque existe
mais elle est composée d'une multitude
de sites et états qui sont opposées les
unes aux autres et qui se font la guerre
plus le temps et cette dislocation du
monde grec cette division en politique
conduit à un phénomène de chauvinisme en
fait d'angers l'une des cités où il ya
quand même une très forte notion de
solidarité civique entre les citoyens
art opposition aux autres grecs à ceux
des autres cités et donc on alors le cas
extrêmes c'est celui de sparte et
extrêmement fermé aux étrangers qui
régulièrement pratiquer des sortes de
d'expulsion globale de tous les
étrangers y compris d'ailleurs les
voyageurs les touristes qui se
trouvaient à ce moment là avec en plus
l'idée que ce parc est toujours menacée
parce que ce parti c'est très très peu
d'habitants aller à son apogée ses huit
mille citoyens et à l'époque même
d'aristote encore ses mille citoyens
donc c'est vraiment une toute petite
tribu finalement qui a toujours peur que
un élément étranger vienne peut-être
donner de mauvaises idées aux enjeux de
ce parti est par exemple d'adopter la
démocratie et donc on se ferme aux
étrangers donc dans ces conditions là
évidemment pas question d'assimiler un
étranger de le rendre spartiates sa part
est totalement inenvisageable pour les
athéniens qui sont un peu plus ouvert
que les spartiates
c'est pas non plus un terrain très
propice à l'assimilation puisque les
athéniens considère quand même à partir
de l'époque la 6e pour être athéniens il
faut être né de père et de mère
athéniens et
et certes athènes reçoit des étrangers
sur son toit il ya des immigrés qui
viennent fameux métèques
mais c'est d'étrangers non a vocation à
rejoindre la communauté des citoyens
athéniens ce ne sont pas de père et mère
athéniens ils ne sont jamais vraiment
athénien est d'ailleurs la vie la vie
quotidienne elle même les sépare c'est à
dire qu' il ya des gymnases des théâtres
qui sont réservées aux citoyens et qui
exclut les étrangers et donc dans ces
conditions là à part quelques rares
exceptions on assigne pas c'est à dire
qu'on ne rend pas athéniens des gens qui
ne serait pas d'origine athénien est
donc le monde grec de l'époque classique
et assez peu assez peu aux simulateurs
et est en fait tout ça commence à
changer un peu dans les mentalités à
partir du 4e siècle avant jésus-christ
juste avant alexandre le grand en fait
juste avant les conquêtes d'alexandre et
on voit par exemple un orateur grec
athéniens qui s'appelle isocrate il le
premier commence à théoriser l'idée que
peut-être en fait la civilisation
grecque
quelque chose de plus grand que les
différentes cités grecques et même
peut-être qu'elle pourrait s'étendre en
fait à une autre partie du monde à
d'autres hommes que les citoyens grecs
et c'est le début
enfin c'est voilà la première notion que
les l'hellénisme pourrait
s'universaliser et par conséquent être
assimilée par d'autres populations tout
ça raphaël devant va se terminer par
l'élimination de l'egypte puisque
cléopâtre que nous connaissons tous bien
cléopâtre et une grecque en tout cas
elle a un prénom grecque est les grecs
elle règne sur l'egypte et
mais son débreak oui en fait c'est le
résultat des conquêtes d'alexandre le
grand justement qui fait vraiment passé
le monde grec avec nouvelle dimension
puisque le même et n'ai pas tout à fait
grec puisqu'ils les macédoniens enfin il
appartient à cette sphère culturelle
grecque
et comme il a conquis la perse l'egypte
tous les territoires en fait qui vont
jusqu'à ce que au nord de l'inde
ce les grecs se retrouve à la tête de
population très diverse très étrangère à
leur propre culture
voilà des persos égyptien et et donc il
faut bien décidé que fois faire de ces
différentes populations
c'était donc un problème tout à fait
nouveau pour les grecs qui n'avait
jamais eu cette situation auparavant et
on voit qu alexandre qui est noir très
jeune on sait pas vraiment ce qu'aurait
pu donner et l'empiré d'alexandre s'il
avait vécu jusqu'à un âge avancé mais on
voit quelques initiatives d'alexandre
que il avait quand même une certaine
idée de à quoi ressemblerait son futur
empire est par exemple il avait créé un
régiment était composée de jeunes
iraniens john perse mais qu'il avait
éduquer à la grecque qui l'avait fait
apprendre le grec
il la prend à qui il avait enseigné à
apprendre à combattre à la grecque et ce
régiment il avait appelé les héritiers
et donc on voit avec ce genre de symbole
qui n'est pas qu'un symbole puisque en
pratique ça et les dix est effectivement
de jeunes de jeu des iraniens et mais
cette initiative montré que à terme il y
allait avoir un empire où on ne sera pas
forcément de sens grec d'origine grecque
mais qu'on pourrait participer à la
culture grecque avec certains rapports
évidemment des des populations qui avait
été conquise puisqu'alexandre revêt
certains et certaines coutumes un
certain uniforme aussi de l' empire
perse
donc il ya un mais certaines échanges
mais tout de même la culture dominante
de ce nouvel empire et la culture grecs
et ensuite alors l'empiré d'alexandre se
disloque en une série de vampires
distincts mais ses successeurs ces
différents successeurs poursuivre d'une
manière générale cette politique qui
consiste à aller enfin à envisager que
plus tard ces différentes populations se
réuniront sous la culture grecque alors
c'est pas tout à fait systématiquement
on n'est pas encore sous la troisième
république française dans sa volonté
presque maniaque d'assimilation mais on
voit certaines certaines tentatives
certains réflexes et commencent à
apparaître pour essayer effectivement de
transformer les égyptiens en grec en
tout cas de leur faire apprendre le grec
que d'imposer le grec comme langue
administrative de permettre les mariages
mixtes parfois d encourager même pour
qu' il est métis qui puisse ensuite
diffuser encore la culture grecque et
tout ça donc suit son cours à la fin de
cette époque on appelle hellénistique au
début de l'époque romaine les égyptiens
sont très loin d'être totalement elysées
notamment dans les campagnes mais quand
même on voit beaucoup d'individus
notamment dans les papyrus que les
archéologues ont retrouvé qui
effectivement sont issus de d'origine
égyptienne et pourtant ils parlent pas
bien grecs ils ont des noms grecs
parfois donc on voit que ça n'a pas été
totalement dépourvu de succès et rome à
l'heure où on se souvient tous de la daj
à rome fait ce que les roms un fond nous
même en france nous sommes issus d'une
civilisation gallo-romaine
on en conclut donc que les gaulois ont
été assimilés par les romains que tout
le monde s'habille et à la romaine
autour de la méditerranée que le monde
romain était un monde entièrement
romanisée il y aurait un universalisme
chez les romains qui annonce un peu
l'universalisme tel que nous le
revendiquons aujourd'hui oui je pense
que l'universalisme néo romain est
vraiment une caractéristique très
importante de la rome antique qui la
distingue d'ailleurs des grecs qui ont
fini par se convertir à une certaine
forme d'universalisme mais les grecs
sont quand même beaucoup plus conscients
d'une sorte de privilège grecque et sont
moins ouverts spontanément à l'étranger
et à l'altérité que nous que les romains
les les romains ce dès l'origine
d'ailleurs depuis lors leurs légendes
mythologiques considèrent que leur ville
a été fondée à partir d'un ensemble de
populations assez disparates qui ont été
unifiées au sein de la cité romaine par
par le fondateur légendaire romulus et
en plus c'est une société qui est très
juridique que reposent sur le droit
qu'ils ont en partie inventé et
notamment sur la notion de personne qui
est notion juridique que les romains ont
le coup véritablement inventé et qui
implique en fait de séparer ce qu'est
l'individu d'un point de vue abstrait
dans son rôle social dans son rôle dans
la société par exemple le citoyen romain
est ce qu'il est physiquement ça son
corps sa personne physique est là il
peut être une origine d'une couleur
différente peu importe pour un romain
donc il a le statut juridique de
citoyens romains ce qu'on peut
considérer comme un roman et peu importe
son origine
donc c'est assez important et c'est ce
qui permet justement aux romains de
faire preuve finalement d'assimilation
de manière très spontanée chez eux ce
n'est pas forcément une politique où il
aurait un jour décidé de loi condamne
israël tout le monde dans dans la
méditerranée mais c'est par petites
touches
ils sont toujours plutôt attiré par le
réflexe assimilateur que par nous que
par une autre politique
c'est l'idée qui a guidé chez les
romains que ce qui est bon pour pour eux
est bon pour le monde entier
ce serait ça aussi l'universalisme
c'est l'idée qu'au fond tout ce que nous
connaissons nos coutumes nos croyances
de nos manières de faire pourrait
parfaitement s'exporter et tout le monde
en serait bénéficiaire et achat aussi
chez les américains d'ailleurs
oui en fait les romains sont assez
convaincus de la leur supériorité en
fait pas seulement leur supériorité à
eux mais plutôt de la supériorité de la
civilisation gréco romaine en fait rien
l'historien paul veyne qui a écrit un
livre sur ce sujet là le lempire
gréco-romain c'est à dire sa forme quand
même une sphère culturelle commune à
partir de de la période impériale et les
romains donc sont aussi les vecteurs de
la culture hellénique et de ce qu'on
peut appeler une sorte de modernité
hellénique
les romains sont convaincus que c'est
effectivement ça la civilisation et la
seule et donc quand ils arrivent dans
les territoires celtique
quand ils vont en gaule en angleterre en
bretagne et ou en espagne il le trouve
donc des celtes qui n'ont échangé sap
avec la culture hellénique mais qui ont
les civilisations quand même assez
radicalement différente et les romains
sont choqués de certains traits
culturels de loi par exemple qui
s'empressent d'ailleurs d'interdire et
notamment les sacrifices humains qui
était pratiqué en gaule et que les
empereurs romains les premiers empereurs
romains ont cherché à interdire parce
qu'ils considéraient c'était
contradictoire avec la notion romaine
d'humanité parlez plutôt d'humanité que
civilisation mais c'est pas le même
concept
donc il y avait effectivement cette idée
que d'organiser c'était aussi apporter
la civilisation a porté la modernité et
l'humanité à des peuples qui en
manquaient auparavant
et est ce que vous faites remarquer
c'est que partout autour de la
méditerranée partout le l'empiré romain
s'installe on commence par construire
des termes les termes c'est
véritablement un des moteurs de de la
romanisation oui en fait d'ailleurs non
seulement les termes et les bains mais
de manière générale toute l'architecturé
romaine est en fait l'urbanisme romain
est un facteur un outil d'assimilation
puisque effectivement partout dans
l'empiré vous vous trouvez des villes
qui ont à peu près la même forme qui
sont construites sur le même plan en
damier
ils sont qui contiennent les mêmes
équipements publics dont les fameux
terme
et quand vous êtes un barbare un gaulois
par exemple qui auparavant j'ai plutôt
habituée à la vie dans des stades elle
ou des villages gaulois vous arrivez
dans la cité romaine qui a été
construite par les colons romain et
comme il ya ces équipements publics vous
vaut en profiter et ça vous fait de
venir aux mains
puisque être romain justement c'est ce
n'est pas seulement avoir respecté
romaine mais c'est aussi finalement
reporté la toge dans les grandes
occasions allaient aubin deux fois par
jour
c'est un ensemble de pratiques très
quotidienne et comme en plus c'est vécu
par la plupart des peuples
méditerranéens en fait comme une sorte
de confort du luxe moderne d'avoir
justement les bains éventuellement le
courant dans les cités les cités
romaines et bien c'est attrayant c'est
attractif et cela facilite la
romanisation de ces populations
résultat les romains vont traiter de la
même manière
la bretagne est la grèce par exemple
qu'ils envahissent et également pour y a
pas de différences sont romanisés tout
le monde de la même manière
alors non parce que les romains sont des
gens très pragmatique et comme je disais
tout à l'heure ils n'ont pas de vision
systématique de la romanisation c'est là
qu'il ne cherche pas il n'y a pas un
empereur qui a voulu un jour forcer tout
le monde à s'organiser de manière
uniforme partout dans lé empire donc en
fait c'est plutôt des initiatives
individuelles de certains gouverneurs de
certains généraux et locales qui qui
s'adapte aux circonstances en fait
de là où ils se trouvent et qui essaie
de les amener à la civilisation romaine
on a des exemples du coût individuel par
exemple un général romain rebelles en
fait
l'époque des guerres civiles qui
s'appelle certains russes qui s'établit
en il veut fonder une sorte d'état
roumain rebelles en espagne est la
première chose qu'il fait en fait pour
se procurer des troupes c'est d'essayer
de d'éduquer à la romaine les jeunes des
jeunes enfants des nobles ibérique un
noble cents de l'hispanie et
effectivement ils les envoient à l'école
il leur apprend les grands classiques de
la littérature grecque et romaine il
aurait même la petite bulle qui était
une sorte de médailles qu'on mettait aux
enfants romain parties d'aller à l'école
et il fait des distributions de prix un
peu comme à la belle époque française et
donc c'est ça sa stratégie pour les
ibères de romanisation mais
effectivement ce n'est pas toujours le
cas de la même manière partout et en
particulier vous parliez de la grèce les
romains n'ont pas trop osé essayer
d'organiser la grèce justement parce
qu'ils avaient une sorte de complexe
d'infériorité par rapport aux grecs
elle savait bien que c'était la culture
quand même d'un point de vue
intellectuel artistique la plus la plus
forte et la plus créatrice la plus
ancienne aussi et est donc là en grèce
on ne cherche pas trop à organiser on ne
cherche pas forcément à poser le latin
en plus il ya déjà des villes c'est très
dur très urbanisé l'orient méditerranéen
grâce justement en fait au successeur
d'alexandre dont convient déjà un peu
dans une situation proche de la
civilisation romaine pour cause puisque
en fait c'est la civilisation romaine
qui a copié la civilisation grecque est
donc là ils ont moins essayer
d'organiser et d'ailleurs ça se voit
bien puisqu'en fait la partie orientale
de l'empiré ensuite est devenu l'empiré
byzantin qui a finalement assez peu
gardée de caractéristiques romaine alors
qu'inversement l'empiré d'occident est
devenue l'europe occidentale latine qui
en fait racines de nos pays européens
aujourd'hui il nous reste deux minutes
avant de faire une pause mais le cas de
leucate jérusalem
là il ya de la résistance on veut pas se
faire rhmani zay et puis il ya jésus et
on connaît les romains pour assimiler
c'est à dire on fait prendre pour eux
les les dieux des peuples qu'il
conquiert et là tout à coup il ya
réticences
on veut pas de ce dieu là pourquoi
affectivement avec les chrétiens est un
problème qui se pose est même je trouve
qu'on pourrait presque en parlait comme
d'un problème de séparatisme du point de
vue des romains puisque on a une lettre
très intéressante de pline le jeune qui
est un gouverneur romain et quéven et
gouverneur romain qui se retrouve à la
tête d'une province et on lui apporte
des chrétiens qui ont été dénoncés par
des lettres anonymes en gros est il
écrit à l'empereur trajan pour lui
demander parce qu'il est il est un peu
c'est pas très bien quoi faire et donc
il écrit à l'empereur pour lui demandé
la marche à suivre
qu'est ce que je dois faire quand on m'a
même des chrétiens est ce que je dois
tous et punis est-ce que je dois leur
faire éventuellement leur donner une
chance de de renoncer à jésus-christ et
de sa pitié à l'empereur est ce que je
veux faire autre chose et être agent lui
répondait de manière pragmatique en
disant que les dénonciations anonymes il
faut pas en tenir compte parce que sinon
tout part à vau l'eau et que le plus
important c'est d'abord quand même
d'être sûrs qu'ils ne sont pas assez
dissuasifs est qu'ils ne sont pas utiles
par exemple donc qu'ils respectent le
culte impérial qui en fait une personne
ne croit vraiment que l'empereur est un
dieu mais c'est une sorte de deux
marques de loyauté envers envers
l'empiré qu'envers la romanité
et donc ce sont ceux qui tiennent
tellement à leur nouvelle religion
chrétienne
il refuse donc de faire ce pas vers la
leur est le reste de la société qui sont
qui sont persécutés mais on voit le
problème que ça posait pour les romains
il était vraiment un problème non pas
tellement religieux puisque comme vous
le disiez pour d'autres religions il
n'avait aucun problème a considéré que
soient les dieux des étrangers
s'accumulent s'ajouter aux leurres soi
que les dieux des étrangers en fait
étaient les mêmes que les leurs mais
avec d'autres non avec le monothéisme
évidemment c'est plus compliqué et mais
pour les romains le problème principal
il est quand même politique c'est un
problème de scission de la communauté
civique et c'est ça qui leur fait pas on
fait une pause rappelle dans on se
retrouve juste après
nous sommes toujours avec raphaël deux
ans qui publie le rêve de l'ale
simulation de la grèce antique à nos
jours aux éditions passé composé
un mot sur l' empire al arab au
moyen-âge l'islam et est une religion
assimilatrice à cette époque là elle
unifie des territoires absolument
considérable ça va de de l'iran a même
des parties de la chine jusqu'à jusqu'à
l'espagne mais en fait d'ailleurs si
aujourd'hui on parle de monde arabe
c'est grâce à cette assimilation en fait
à vos musulmane puisque à l'origine les
arabes désignent qu'une partie de la
population de la péninsule arabique
donc effectivement il ya eu un mouvement
assez impressionnant d'assimilation et
en fait il ya là ce qui est intéressant
avec le monde islamique c'est qu' il
n'est pas toujours facile de distinguer
entre l'islamisation et l'arabisation le
entre la conversion religieuse mais qui
s'accompagne forcément de pratiques
culturelles et l'arabisation qui
linguistique d'abord c'est la diffusion
de la langue arabe est aussi culturel
puisqu'il ya une culture une
civilisation arabe se réduit pas à des
préceptes religieux et donc il ya unan
entre notre melman de ces deux de ces
deux phénomènes qu'ils arrêtent c'est
intéressant de l'explorer parce qu'en
fait je pense
on voit bien je trouve dans en
s'intéressant cette période que
justement là l'arabisation ne se réduit
pas à la force de l'islam à la force
ils ont universaliste de l'islam qui est
évidemment un atout mais on voit aussi
par exemple des chrétiens en espagne
andalouse qui alors qu'ils ne sont pas
du tout converti à l'islam et qui
continuera d'être chrétien cherche quand
même à adopter la culture arabe à parler
arabe et même à essayer de rivaliser
avec le poète arabe dans la poésie
classique et dans la connaissance de la
littérature arabe ça c'est intéressant
de voir qu'en fait même dans un monde
qui a l'air aussi régi par est aussi
marqué par sa religion que le monde
islamique
l'assimilation ne se réduit pas dans ce
cas une conversion est alors qu à
pratiquement inverse celui des japonais
les japonais eux
on le sait vous refusé pendant des
siècles et des siècles tout apport
étranger ils ne veulent pas d'étrangers
ils veulent rester entre eux
donc là zéro assimilationniste mme way a
priori on pourrait penser que le japon
c'est même le pays le moins propice à
l'assimilation de du monde entier
d'abord parce que effectivement pendant
des siècles ils se sont littéralement
pays du reste du monde alors en
interdisant les voyages à l'étranger
une manière très stricte et aussi parce
qu'aujourd'hui encore ce pays qui
accueillent est extrêmement peu
d'immigrés où il est assez difficile de
s'intégrer quand on est étranger au
japon et donc voilà s'appliquer à l'air
très anti assimilateur et donc il ya une
seule période assez brève mais
importante de l'histoire japonaise ou le
japon s'est montrée assimilateur est en
fait c'est la période coloniale
la planète c'est à dire que le à la fin
du xixème siècle les japonais se rendent
compte que les occidentaux sont en train
rares ont bâti des empires coloniaux
extrêmement puissante et se disent que
pour rivaliser avec les occidentaux il
faut eux aussi ils faisaient un empire
colonial parce que c'est la marque une
grande puissance à la fin du xixème
siècle et est donc c'est comme ça qu'ils
se retrouvent à conquérir d'abord taiwan
la corée puis a moins souri et aussi des
îles plus proche du japon comme okinawa
et est donc ça pose une question tout à
fait nouvelle aux japonais un peu de la
même manière d'ailleurs que les grecs
s'étaient posés des questions nouvelles
après les conquêtes d'alexandre c'est à
dire maintenant on a des populations qui
ne sont pas japonaises qui sont sous
notre gouvernement et il faut savoir
quoi en faire il faut savoir ce qu'on va
proposer comme horizon commun à ces
populations non japonaises puisque juste
auparavant la l'identité japonaise
c'était une identité en fait totalement
fondée sur l'origine et le sens japonais
on était deux pères et mères japonais de
toute façon mais c'est peu des échanges
avec l'étranger
on n'avait pas le choix est donc là les
japonais commencent à considérer la
possibilité que peut-être des taiwanais
des coréens pourraient constituer des
citoyens japonais
c'est une vraie révolution qui a été
finalement écourtée par la fin de
l'empiré colonial japonais qui en plus
ça a été
rendue très difficile par le fait que
les japonais ont adopté des pratiques
coloniales extrêmement brutal lorsque
les rémois en corée où ils ont été très
violents d'heure pratique assimilatrice
justement ils ont renforcé notamment les
enfants coréens à japonisé à marche
forcée de manière assez assez agressive
mais ni messi ni période tout à fait
étonnante dans l'histoire japonaise
puisque ensuite à la fin de cet empire
avec la défaite dans la seconde guerre
mondiale les oblige à abandonner leurs
colonies les japonais finissent par se
dire qu'en fait il est beaucoup mieux et
beaucoup plus progressistes et pacifiste
finalement de se replier sur une
conception de l'identité plus raciale en
fait et plus plus familial au lieu de
cds est une sorte d'universalité
passagers qui leur a fait tant de mal
alors revenons-en au cas de la france la
france au fond elle commence par
assimiler les provinces on est devenu
français bien avant que les allemands
les italiens ou les britanniques eux
deviennent allemands italiens ou
britanniques
on était déjà français mou mais on a
l'impression qu'au fond à être français
c'était faire comme les parisiens oui en
fait la première assimilation française
c'est la simulation de la france a elle
même c'est l'assimilation des français
eux-mêmes et en particulier
effectivement des provinces et les
petits bretons les petits provençaux des
petits l'alsacien qui deviennent
français c'est ça la première forme
française d'assimilation alors
évidemment quand la france à 6000 à
elle-même fallait définir un modèle
il fallait bien que hier modèle de
référence pour ce que c'est quatre
français est en fait le modèle va
spontanément c'est devenu du fait de la
centralité la caractéristique de l'état
français et de la géographie française
ça a été en fait le modèle franciliens
ou parisien qui s'est imposé d'abord
parce que justement comme la capitale
étaient sains comme le pays des très
centralisé autour de cette capitale
il y avait beaucoup d'échangés beaucoup
de brassage à paris et vous avez des
élites
enfin des flux de bourgeois ou de
d'aristocrates venus de province qui
monte à paris puisqu'il revenait et cela
tous à favoriser la diffusion des moeurs
de la culture parisienne
et puis même parfois une vraie volonté
politique
par exemple le mazarin
cherche à peu avant sa mort a justement
donné une culture française comme une
jeune aristocrate issus des provinces
qui venait d'être annexée à la france
d'avant la franche comté le roussillon
en créant le collège des quatre nations
qui était un collège où on réunissait
des des jeunes des jeunes membres de
l'aristocratie nouvelle pour leur donner
une éducation communes qui seraient
unifiée et ensuite on les renvoie chez
eux pour qu'ils aillent sorte prêcher la
bonne parole et rediffusé cette culture
tôt parisienne dans le reste de la
france
une fois qu'on a bien eut dit fier tout
ça il ya les immigrés alors les émigrés
il arrive plus tardivement qu'on
croirait en réalité c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui vient avec la
révolution industrielle la révolution
industrielle vient assez tard en france
enfin plutôt qu'ailleurs mais quand même
plus tard qu en angleterre donc c'est
napoléon iii l'immigration au fond ces
postes second empire et que là comment
est ce qu'on va faire
oui parce qu'effectivement sous l'ancien
régime il ya les mouvements migratoires
sont plus faibles on a quelques cas
effectivement de portugais ou de
néerlandais qui s'installe en france
mais c'est plus minime et donc
l'immigration en france se développe de
manière plus massive à la fin du xixème
siècle comme vous l'avez dit avec la à
l'époque industrielle
on a effectivement des italiens des
espagnols des européens qui s'installe
qui laisse s'installer et travailler en
france et donc là on sait le moment où
la troisième république codifie légifère
et théorise aussi l'assimilation à la
française telle qu'on en parle
aujourd'hui
alors en fait c'était il ya des racines
quand même plus ancienne que ça à
l'assimilation française même pour les
étrangers on a parlé de l'assimilation
delà des français eux-mêmes mais il y
avait aussi toute la période coloniale
y compris aux xviie et au xviiie siècle
qui avait été une sorte de laboratoire
elle aussi de l'assimilation française
par exemple au canada dans le canada
français sous louis xiv ou colbert avait
eu l'idée d'essayer de franciser comme
on disait à l'époque les indiens
d'amérique avec l'idée que cela si
finalement les britanniques arrivés à
faire venir beaucoup de colons anglais
en amérique du nord que ça devenait donc
une sorte de rivalité démocratique
il fallait aussi développer la
démographie des colonies françaises en
amérique
sauf que les français n'avaient pas
tellement envie de s'installer
aussi le roi ne voulait pas trop des
peuples et son royaume et donc colbert
se dit bien après tout il ya des gens
là-bas ce sont les indiens on va en
faire des français et donc il y avait
déjà un peu ce réflexe la même pour des
étrangers étrangers radicaux comme les
indiens à l'époque de pouvoir en faire
des français et on voit déjà une marque
de l'universalisme français qui se
manifeste ici avant même la révolution
française
ensuite donc arrive justement la
révolution française ou en plus en plus
de ce cette tendance qui était déjà
présente sur l'ancien régime on ajoute
les droits de l'homme et tous les idéaux
universels dégagé pendant la révolution
française et à la suite de la
philosophie des lumières est donc là on
se sent encore plus légitime en france à
imposer à des étrangers des manières de
vivre et des façons de voir le monde
françaises et donc même sous napoléon
puisque là aussi on a été confronté à
des étrangers puis on est allés chez eux
elle compte n'en revêt la moitié de
l'europe et qu'on a connue en italie par
exemple cherche vraiment à franciser les
italiens et ils poussent le degré du
détail jusqu'à imposer par exemple que
dans les opéras italiens il soit
interdit de dîners ou de jouer aux
cartes dans les loges de l'opéra ce qui
était une pratique concert d'italie à
l'époque ne se faisait pas à paris et
donc à brûler on va jusqu'à interdire
aux italiens aux italiens de de manger
dans leur loge à l'opéra voilà ce qu'on
donne une idée du degré de détail de
l'assimilation descente en france qui
est aussi une contrainte administrative
en fait alors ce qu'est ce qu'il ya de
bien c'est que ça fait que pour les
français dits de couleurs
il ya absolument en france aucune
ségrégation aucun racisme officiel
d'état aucune loi qui les discriminent
de quelques manières que ce soit et ils
vous racontais que ça va poser des
problèmes avec les américains qui
arrivent de plus en plus nombreux en
france à partir de là de la première
guerre mondiale et qui vont venir dans
les années 20 ils ne comprennent pas ils
comprennent pas que les noirs rentrer
dans les établissements ça soit un codé
de et soient considérées alors égale ça
les choque énormément
et oui parce que effectivement alors oui
il ya des occasions évidemment de
racisme en france d'un titre individuel
mais il n'y a pas de ségrégation
administratives comme en amérique n'a
pas de politique d'état qui soit qu'il
soit collectivement raciste et donc
quand les américains arrivent après la
première guerre mondiale comme vous
l'avez dit en france et que donc on a
des soldats des policiers américains qui
vivent quelques mois en france sa
posture des problèmes on a par exemple
un cas d'un policier américain qui abat
après une seule sommation un français un
français noir avec une sorte de crime de
crimes de police raciste typique de ce
qu'on a en amérique
déjà à l'époque parfois encore
aujourd'hui sauf que ça fait hurler les
français qui considèrent une part
évidemment c'est un américain qui tue
quelqu'un sur le sol français ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas très agréable mais en
plus on considère que c'est vraiment
barbares que c'est bien la marque d'un
pays raciste et rétrograde et le quai
d'orsay ensuite prend vraiment les
choses à bras le corps pour notifier aux
américains que ce genre de pratique est
absolument inacceptable en france et
c'est le cas évidemment non seulement
pour des affaires graves comme aussi
grave que le meurtre mais aussi pour
deux affaires comme dans les boîtes de
nuit les restaurants et dans l'est et
les balles
quand le certains parce que comme il y
avait pas mal de touristes et de
voyageurs américains à paris dans les
villes françaises les restaurateurs les
tenants de base et de deux salles de
spectacle et détente et de faire plaisir
à ses clients et à ses riches en
appliquant les mêmes règles qu'en
amérique donc en instaurant la
ségrégation à l'intérieur de leur
établissement
et donc quand on sent quand ça commence
à se répandre l'administration française
le gouvernement réagit de manière très
sévère en interdisant formellement ce
genre de pratique est en même en
envoyant un communiqué de presse du quai
d'orsay pour dire aux américains que
c'est inacceptable
et donc on voit vraiment la divergence
totale de conception du monde et de la
relation entre les hommes et le rapport
à l'étranger qu'ont les américains et
les français cette époque là oui parce
que vous le dites bien les américains de
l'america été assimilationniste elle
aussi comme l'avs comme la france mais
pas pour tout le monde c'est à dire pas
pour les noirs pas pour les indiens et
qui on va bien le voir ensuite au fur et
à mesure ils vont toujours préféré de
toutes façons les les blancs protestants
que les latinos ou les où les hindous
mais en fait c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on a tendance à voir dans l'amérique une
sorte de bastion du multiculturalisme
comme s'il avait toujours été le cas en
fait c'est un peu plus nuancé puisque
comme vous le dites les américains ont
eu une politique assimilatrice dans leur
histoire qui c'est qui a pris fin il ya
connu une sorte d'apogée à l'époque de
la première guerre mondiale justement
qui ensuite a pris fin dans la deuxième
moitié du xxème siècle et donc le
multiculturalisme américain est plutôt
une tradition plutôt récente le problème
de leur politique assimilatrice et a
bien marché pour les immigrés européens
puisque la réussit quand même à
transformer effectivement des italiens
des germains des des allemands des
anglais en vrai mec qu'on se souvienne
parce que plus d'ailleurs de leurs
origines européennes
en revanche elle avait un énorme bang le
mort cette politique d'assimilation qui
était effectivement les minorités noires
et amérindiennes et c'était énorme c'est
à dire que les les noirs ne pouvais même
s'il faisait les efforts pour le faire
pour s'assimiler pour devenir totalement
identique à aux anglo saxons se voyait
refuser l'entrée dans cette communauté
par par la majorité blanche américaine
et donc ça a été je pense d'ailleurs la
source de l'abandon de l'assimilation
par les américains puisque pour du 20e
siècle
ça a été de plus en plus perçu comme une
sorte d'hypocrisie blanche en fait qui
visait à rejeter ces minorités hors de
la société privilégiée américaine et
donc du tout une assimilation en fait
puisque l'assimilation par principe
impose de donner à celui qu'on assimile
exactement la même place les mêmes
droits a le même statut dans la société
d'accueil que n'importe quel autre
membre
donc en fait le l'assimilation ne peut
que s'effondrer si jamais elle est la
partie liée avec une forme de racisme ou
de condescendance et c'est ce qui fait
passer pour nous dans notre empire
colonial puisque évidemment ni les
algériens ni les indochinois n'avait les
mêmes de l'eau les mêmes droits que les
que les français d'origine y compris
dans leur propre pays
voilà le problème en fait de la
simulation coloniale française c'est que
il ya une distorsion permanente entre la
théorie
enfin validé à l'ambition disons des
gouvernements français de l'époque
coloniale et la réalité de l'expérience
coloniale
c'est globalement quand même les
gouvernements sont enfin affirme avoir
une politique assimilatrice et disons
généreuse entre guillemets c'est à dire
que à terme les les habitants des
colonies se verront tous confié la
société française pleine avec un effet
juridique complet évidemment ça n'est
jamais arrivé à part ceux qui étaient
venus en métropole
et puis en fait c'était vraiment
naturalisé mai mais c'était une sorte de
de dorison va lequel on était censé
avancées et en pratique ça se poser en
fait à la latitude la plus courante des
colons qui ceux qui étaient sur place
les français qui étaient sur place
puisque eux n'avaient pas vraiment
intérêt en fait d'un point de vue
purement égoïste à l'assimilation des
indigènes puisque comme je dis fut
d'ailleurs assimilés ça veut dire rendre
égale ça veut dire donner les mêmes
droits et et pour les alors que les
colons il était privilégiée dans les
colonies et il avait une sorte de statut
supérieur et donc forcément
l'assimilation leur plaisait pas
tellement parce que ça voulait dire
appliquer leur supériorité alors village
et donc le comportement en général des
colons est plutôt contraire là plutôt
freiné en fait le mécanisme assimilateur
par exemple en rabaissant en rabaissant
l'étranger ou en pratiquant en ayant des
réflexions racistes et ça c'est vraiment
le problème fondamental en fait de la
colonisation et la simulation français
c'est qu'on n'a jamais résolu cette
distorsion au fond vous dites qu alors
revenons en métropole là où on a
toujours voulu assimilés jusqu'à jusqu'à
présent y compris ceux qui étaient
fichus de notre empire colonial mais qui
était venu en france et qui avait réussi
à se faire naturaliser français
ce moment la demande venait des français
comme les autres
et pourtant cette cette politique
assimilationniste elle va être
abandonnée dans les années 70 80
alors au profit de quoi et quelle est la
situation aujourd'hui raphaël
effectivement on a eu une période en
métropole une sorte d'apogée de
l'assimilation qui était donc je la
mettrais entre les années entre la
première et la deuxième guerre mondiale
finalement ou la troisième république a
vraiment parfait une sorte de deux
monuments juridique une architecture
juridique qui permet qui facilite
l'assimilation assez complète des
immigrés qui s'installe en france à
cette époque là d'abord il ya le rôle
joué par l'école c'est le tout le tissu
d'instituteurs et de professeurs qui a
été déployée par la troisième république
et qu'on connaît bien les lois de de
jules ferry
c'est donc l'école qui sert d'abord à
finir le travail de francisation des
français eux-mêmes dont on parlait tout
à l'heure
interdisant par exemple systématiquement
le patois usage du patois à l'école dans
les provinces le patois était encore
utilisé et qui est de la même manière
pour les immigrés italiens et des autres
européens
on leur imposait aussi d'apprendre
l'histoire de france de la même manière
que les français ces deux fameux nos
ancêtres les gaulois et on leur apprend
le français enfin bref l'école est un
outil très efficace d'assimilation on a
aussi une machine administrative qui
concerne la naturalisation puisque en
fait le ski va constituer le le goulot
d'étranglement que soit enfin le filtre
permettant d'assimiler ou de considérer
qu elle n'est pas assimilée ça va être
le moment où l'étranger demandent à être
naturalisé français à être citoyen
français
à ce moment là en fait l'administration
de cette époque récolte énormément
d'informations mais une simple enquête
va demander au maire du village où vous
habitez va demander va demander à votre
entourage aux proches si effectivement
vous viviez vraiment à la france est si
vous avez vraiment des fréquentations
française si vous vous élevez votre vos
enfant à la française bref si vous
partagez l'ensemble des ses coutumes qui
font la civilité française et donc le
l'administration à cette époque en plus
vraiment des questionnaires énorme avec
des cinquantaine de questions sur le
degré d'assimilation de l'individu qui
demande à être fait citoyen français et
donc 7,7
sa machinerie administrative qui est
lourde qui demande beaucoup d'efforts
d'ailleurs de la part de
l'administration elle même était assez
efficace
en tout cas les vagues d'immigration
européenne de la fin du 19ème siècle et
du début du 20e siècle ont été assez
bien absorbé par le corps social
français
et effectivement c'est à partir de là
dans l'après guerre des années 60-70 ce
qu'on voit reculer cet effort
assimilateur et notamment qu'on voit le
mot même d'assimilation être remis en
question puis progressivement abandonner
alors je disais tout à l'heure que
c'était lié à la fin de l'an pire
puisque l'assimilation donc a été une
politique en partie coloniale et qu'une
fois qu'on était qu'on avait des
colonisés et que maintenant l'empiré
reçues quand même comme un mauvais
souvenir
on les connotations coloniale du mot
assimilation n'était pas vraiment du
goût de tout le monde donc on a
commencéà sans distance en plus même
matériellement les années le début des
années 70 sur une période où on pense
qu'on va plus vraiment avoir besoin
d'assez minet puisque d'une part dont on
a célébré les colonies qui ont pris leur
indépendance et en plus on pensait aussi
que on mettrait fin à ce moment à
l'immigration de travail ouais en fait
tomber des fins les migrations de
travail et on n'imaginait pas que plus
tard il y aurait une émigration continue
qui s'est poursuivie après dans les
décennies suivantes
donc il y avait l'idée que la france
serait finalement un peu fermée sur
elle-même que on avait plus de colonies
assimiler mais qu'on aurait pu non plus
d'immigrés assimilés et donc on a on a
pu relâcher en quelque sorte l'effort
d'assimilation il ya une troisième
raison qui est que les plus
intellectuels est plus philosophique qui
est l'influencent de certains penseurs
cela que les américains ont appelé de la
french theory dans les années soixante
dix les foucault deleuze derrida qui ont
alors là je résume vraiment
grossièrement est une manière un peu
simpliste mais globalement ont défendu
des philosophies qui sont devenus très
vite populaire selon lesquelles ce qu'il
fallait valoriser c'est plutôt
l'individualité là l'originalité
éventuellement la minorité plutôt que
l'uniformité que la majorité que
l'homogénéité et 7
cette philosophie cette façon de penser
et est quand même plutôt contraire à
l'assimilation parce que l'assimilation
ça implique de désiré ressembler un
groupe majoritaire donc si on commence à
vous dire qu'en fait il est formidable
c'est de valoriser votre propre
singularité ça devient plus difficile
d'assimiler et d'exiger la simulation
donc il ya un ensemble de raisons à la
fois matérielle et intellectuelle qui
ont fait qu'on a commencé à abandonner
la simulation à partir des années sont
mais est ce que justement l'assimilation
en tant que tel est ce que ça n'est pas
daté à une époque comme la nôtre où les
échanges sur tous les plans sont
considérables où on peut vivre enfance
et regarder une télévision russe ou une
télévision arabe des télévisions
américaines où les gens circulent ou les
où on dans les supermarchés on peut
manger mexicain hindous italien chinois
vouloir assimiler les gens est-ce que ça
n'est pas dérisoire ça me fait penser à
l'australie qui jusqu'à après la seconde
guerre mondiale tout à coup c'est dit
faudrait peut-être faire venir des gens
on était quand même très seule et très
loin de l'angleterre pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale aux mamans ont été
menacés par les japonais on peut plus se
contenter d'avoir que des wasps donc on
va faire venir des italiens ils
acceptent de faire venir pour la
première fois des immigrés italiens et
le première chose qu'ils font avec ces
immigrés italiens c'est d'imposer aux
femmes des cours de cuisine australienne
comme si la cuisine australienne
méritait qu'on la prenne à des femmes
qui savait faire la cuisine italienne
bref passons mais est-ce que ça na pas
est-ce que n'a pas ça n'a pas perdu son
sens que de vouloir assimiler
je ne pense pas c'est pas eu son sens et
je pense que ça va tellement pas perdu
son sens
en fait nous faisons encore de
l'assimilation un peu sans savoir en
france parce que le cercle mot a disparu
du débat public mais je pense pas du
tout que la chose est vraiment disparu
la preuve c'est qu'en fait
je pense qu'à chaque fois que nous
prenons des initiatives et des lois sur
sur les questions qui sont liées à
l'islam aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils sont
les plus brûlantes en france
actuellement
en fait je pense que nous faisons nous
prenons des mesures assimilatrice nous
n'utilisons plus le terme et nous ont
vraiment assumé le concept mais en fait
c'est ça la loi de 2004 sur le voile à
l'école
elle a été justifiée par le concept de
laïcité mais c'était un peu tordre la
laïcité puisque la laïcité implique
normalement d'abord la neutralité des
agents publics c'est à dire que tous les
professeurs en l'occurrence et pas des
usagers des services publics étaient les
élèves et donc on s'est servi la laïcité
un peu comme une sorte de cache sexe
d'une volonté qui en fait est
assimilatrice on a on a voulu simplement
que les jeunes filles musulmanes se
prennent à l'habitude de s'habiller en
fait à la française et de renoncer à une
pratique culturelle le port du voile
on considère spontanément majorité des
français considère qu'elle n'est pas
conforme à la civilité française comme
disait le président de la république et
donc je pense que toutes les polémiques
qu'on a sur par exemple le burqini
encore récemment ou sur la burqa et ou
sur le label ceux qui ne veulent pas
serrer la main des femmes par exemple
enfin bref tout ce qui a trait à ces
pratiques culturelles et la région
musulmane je pense qu'en fait c'est un
problème d'assimilation de nos opposants
et le réflexe français est toujours en
fait de chercher à assimiler de chercher
à faire rentrer ces populations dans
leurs entre guillemets de la culture
française avec les obligations qu on y
est on y associe d'ailleurs sa révolte
en général les observateurs anglo saxons
qui comprennent pas du tout pourquoi on
cherche à on a fait cette loi sur le
voile à l'école par exemple pour eux
c'est invraisemblable et d'ailleurs au
canada par exemple c'est tout à fait
normal
une policière portent le voile en france
ça nous paraît très très choquant je
pense pas que ce soit dû à la simplement
à la neutralité du service public je
pense que c'est notre réflexe
assimilateur cherche toujours en fait à
quand même homogénéiser la
culturellement la société et on a du mal
à s'en défaire même quand on a abandonné
le concept d'assimilation donc on est un
peu des monsieur jourdain qui pratiquons
l'assimilation sans le savoir
et puis pour revenir sur ce que vous
disiez sur le fait effectivement on a
maintenant une culture très mondialisé
avec des échanges et des influences qui
viennent de partout dans le monde
c'est vrai mais je pense que la
simulation peut porter sur des choses un
peu plus
importante disons que dans la vie d'un
individu que de savoir si on mange de la
pizza ou des sushis ou ou du mcdonald's
parce que ça peut avoir à voir par
exemple avec la réception d'antan gérald
darmanin il trouvait ça très choquant de
voir des linéaires de supermarchés
consacré la viande halal ou au guacamole
donc
je pense que tout va un peu exagéré de
sa part d'ailleurs mais mais en fait
voilà les pratiques culinaires ça va ça
vient
en revanche la façon par exemple dont on
envisage les relations hommes-femmes ça
c'est quelque chose d'assez lourd dans
une société et c'est assez difficile de
faire vivre ensemble des gens qui ne
partagent pas des positions suffisamment
commune sur ce genre de problème est-ce
que forcément ça peut mener à une sorte
de séparation des groupes au sein de la
société
c'est ça d'ailleurs je pense qu'on
entend par séparatisme dans la loi
actuelle
après je ne sais pas si comme on refuse
aussi de vraiment assimilé
on est un peu au milieu du gué on est
entre deux chaises je pense d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a plus de mal
à assimiler qu'avant c'est parce qu'on
n'assume pas mais je ne crois pas qu'on
que ni la l'idée ni la réalité ce
devenue ringarde
avec l'évolution du monde merci raphaël
dont le rêve de lait similaire à celle
de la grèce antique à nos jours
ça vient de paraître chez passé composé
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
au prochain numéro
[Musique]